-From Studio 6B
in Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's a special
five-minute edition
of "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
It's the Fallon Five!
♪♪
-Welcome to the Fallon Five!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're gonna be checking in
throughout the Olympics
with five-minute mini shows
now that "The Tonight Show"
is back in Studio 6B
with a full audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
To kick things off,
it's the end of the week,
and I need to catch up
with some personal stuff.
I'm running a bit behind,
so if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank you notes right now,
if that's okay with you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
Thank you, table tennis,
for being the only Olympic sport
you can train for
in your stepdad's basement.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Olympic precautions,
like social distancing.
That's why this year's logo
went from this
to this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, dressage,
for not going by
your original name,
horse prom.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, shot-putters,
for always looking like
you're taking a phone call
on a little metal ball.
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Hold on.
Huh?
♪♪
Thank you, Olympic medals made
from recycled electronics,
for ensuring that
some lucky athlete
is gonna wear the iPhone 4
I threw out in 2013.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I made it.
♪♪
Thank you, fencing,
for being the perfect sport
for beekeepers who have
always wanted to say,
"You killed my father.
Now prepare to die."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
synchronized swimming,
for basically being
underwater TikTok.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, race walking,
for being the Olympic sport
that looks like
all of the competitors
just drank too much cold brew
and are looking
for the nearest bathroom.
Ugh! Tss, tss, eeh!
Not now, not now!
-Do I need a key?
♪♪
-Thank you, water polo,
or as I like to call you,
try-not-to-drown soccer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's the Fallon Five!
Thank you for watching.
And good luck to all
of this year's Olympians.
See you tomorrow night!
[ Cheers and applause ]